Malerische Landschaften,
schroffe Bergwelten,
grüne Täler und kleine Bauerndörfer
– das alles bietet die neue
Wanderroute über die Alpen.
Start ist in Süddeutschland.
Erst mal geht es noch ganz
gemütlich in Gmund am Tegernsee los.
Die Teilnehmer der Wandergruppe
haben eines gemeinsam:
Keiner ist geübter Bergsteiger.
Alle sind gespannt,
ob die eigenen Fähigkeiten für die
siebentägige Tour ausreichen.
Ich hab‘ gelesen, dass man an einigen, ja,
recht alpinen hohen Gipfeln vorbeikommt,
aber dass der Weg doch recht
angenehm und gemütlich zu gehen ist,
dass auf, ja, auf der Strecke auch ’n
paar schöne Gasthäuser liegen,
von daher, ja, einfach ’n paar
schöne Tage in den Bergen.
Schöne Eindrücke,
schöne Strecken zum Laufen,
und dann lass ich mich mal überraschen.
Die Tour führt auf leichten bis
mittelschweren Wegen
zum Alpenhauptkamm hinauf.
Die gesamte Strecke ist
110 Kilometer lang.
Der Österreicher Georg Pawlata
hat sich die Route ausgedacht.
Der besondere Reiz einer
Alpenüberquerung ist,
dass man sozusagen von zu Hause
starten kann in Deutschland
und dann über verschiedene Regionen
bis in den Süden hinunter kommt.
Dabei unterschiedliche Kulturen zu erleben,
unterschiedliche Landschaften zu sehen.
Ein Vorteil dieser Tour: Das schwere Gepäck
wird mit dem Auto hinterher gebracht.
Drei Tage wandert die Gruppe durch
Süddeutschland Richtung Österreich.
Hinter der Grenze wird es
langsam anstrengender:
Es geht hinauf auf 1.800 Meter.
Dabei erfahren die Wanderer
auch einiges über die Bergregion.
Der Granit ist so hartes Gestein,
dass das alles oberirdisch abfließt,
und deswegen sind hier überall diese
kleinen Bäche auch voll mit Wasser.
Übrigens bestes Trinkwasser. Kann
man überall die Wasserflasche auffüllen.
Seit Jahrtausenden wandern
Menschen über die Alpen.
Im 17. Jahrhundert
wurde die Alpenüberquerung
zur Bildungsreise für Adlige.
Die bekannteste Alpenüberquerung
der Geschichte aber
ist die des karthagischen Heerführers
Hannibal 218 vor Christus.
Er zog mit Elefanten über die Berge.
Vom Mythos Alpenüberquerung
zum Freizeitspaß:
Heute wandern auch immer
mehr junge Leute.
Jeder, der mal eine Wanderung
unternommen hat
und dann am Abend müde ins Bett fällt,
hungrig ins Bett fällt,
dann sieht: Uh, da habe ich mir
wirklich was Gutes getan,
eine Sportart eigentlich,
die nicht besonders extrem ist,
gelenkschonend, und trotzdem
verbrennt man viele Kalorien.
Am sechsten Tag kommt der
Höhepunkt der Alpenüberquerung:
der Aufstieg zum Hauptkamm
auf 2.246 Metern.
Bei kühlen fünf Grad Celsius
passieren die Wanderer
den Talübergang am Pfitscher Joch
und erreichen zum ersten Mal Italien.
Bravo, wir haben‘s geschafft. Willkommen
in Italien, Südtirol. Yeahh, endlich.
Also, es ist wahnsinnig schön.
Es san [sind] gewaltige Eindrücke.
Das Panorama, ja, das erschlagt [erschlägt]
einen so fast a bissel [ein bisschen].
Der letzte Streckenabschnitt führt
hinunter ins Pfitscher Tal.
Die Gruppe wandert durch
blühende Sommerwiesen,
vorbei an urigen Bauernhöfen,
bis sie am Ende der Tour
in Sterzing ankommt.
Sterzing, auf Italienisch „Vipiteno“, ist
die nördlichste Stadt des Landes.
Zeit für ein Fazit.
Viele Regionen kennengelernt.
Die Natur ist sehr abwechslungsreich.
Hat mir alles sehr gut gefallen.
Besonders hat mir diese
unglaubliche Vielfalt gefallen –
zum einen der Landschaft,
dass man ja angefangen hat
in diesem lieblichen
Mittelgebirgsgelände am Tegernsee
und dann hochgestiegen ist bis
in alpine Welten am Pfitscherjoch.
Man braucht kein Sportler sein,
dass man es machen kann,
und i werd [ich werde] auf jeden Fall
noch amal [einmal] eine
Alpenüberquerung machen im Herbst.
Zur Belohnung nach sieben
Tagen in Wanderschuhen
kommt in Sterzing etwas
Deftiges auf den Tisch.
Knödelspeisen sind eine
Delikatesse in dieser Region.
Dazu ein Südtiroler Wein
– so ist der Muskelkater in den
Waden ganz schnell vergessen.